-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"#AwkwardDate" tweets from
you guys. Here we go.
This first one's from
@Jeff-Hofmann.
He says...
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Starting now?
-"I'm good, starting now."
-"I had enough of this dating.
This one's from @lms-ladybug
She says...
Ew.
[ Laughter ]
-Ew.
-Gross.
-Oh, my God.
-Good Lord.
-Class.
-Yeah, class act.
This one's from @HeidiHoNayber
She says...
[ Chuckles ] First date.
-Ah.
-There you go.
This one's from @AmberConn1.
She says...
-Hey.
[ Applause ]
Hey.
-You know how it is.
-Yeah.
-You know. Guy keeps up with
his responsibilities.
-No biggie, man.
This one's from @noodlez56
He says...
-Oh.
-Anyways...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-That's the way to --
-Good plan.
-The way to find out.
-I think he's still not gonn
get the right name.
-That's true.
Yeah, those baristas
screw it up, yeah.
This one's from
@discob4breakdon.
[ Laughter ]
-Discob4breakdon?
-Oh, break of dawn.
-Break of dawn?
-But discob4breakdon.
-Breakdong?
-No, Don.
-Don.
-Like Don Quixote.
-Yes.
Like Donald Quixote.
-[ Laughs ]
And Don --
-The windmill --
the windmill's around.
-Him and Sancho Panza.
-Sancho Panza, of course.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from
@discob4breakdon.
He says...
[ Laughs ]
"Oh, yeah, I married you."
-"Hey, yeah. You won."
-"That was awkward."
Yeah, it wasn't that awkward
-"This girl was awful."
-Yeah.
-"Smelled like cheese."
-This one's from @megsmith06
She says...
"Smart."
"Yes."
"Athletic."
"Funny."
"Yes."
[ Chuckles ]
-Ew.
-Yeah, a girl --
-Tattoo of himself
drinking a 40? Yes.
-Of course, man.
Has a tattoo of his other buddy,
his friend.
This one's from @ma-dre13.
She says...
-♪♪ Womp, womp, womp ♪♪
-What?
-You don't do that?
-Oh.
-No, he doesn't play
the trombone.
You're like, "No."
That's a tuba, not a trombone.
That's a -- That's a sousaphone.
This last one's from
@ElloElloBeepBop.
She says...
There you go.
That's the "Tonight Show"
hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now, I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"#MyFamilyIsWeird" stories fro
you guys.
This first one is from
@KimJohnston.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @lay22089.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
That is weird.
-Yeah.
-That is weird.
This one's from
@MariaBarnes96.
She said...
-Oh!
Not sexy.
-This one's from
@garretsatfield.
I like that name.
-Garret Satfield?
-Garret Satfield.
It sounds like somebody
I would be friends with.
-Yeah.
-"Oh, I went out
for dinner the other night
with Garret Satfield."
-How is Garret?
-He's fantastic, as always
Just a positive dude,
always nice.
-That's good.
-He's married.
-Wife is lovely.
-Wife is great too.
-Linda is lovely.
-Yeah.
We're having the Satfields
over for dinner again
'cause I had
so much fun last night.
-Oh, my gosh.
-I'm gonna do it every night
of the week.
-Oh, my gosh. He's so fun.
You know how fun he is?
-Who? You talking about GS
-Yeah, GS. [ Laughs ]
Garr-Man. The Garrster.
Yeah, he's fantastic!
-Yeah.
I just love Garret Satfield.
-Really?
How much do you love him?
-Well, I mean...
I mean,
I love my wife and my kids
-Right.
-But above all, Garry Satfield
[ Laughter ]
He says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
"Grandpa!
"Grandpa,
we're at yellow right now!
-"Take the blanket with you!
-[ Laughs ]
"I'm about to go yellow."
"Oh, what does that mean?"
-"Brown light!"
-Alright. "Brown light."
That's...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @DaniMichelle.
She says...
Oh, my God.
-Yay, Dad!
"It's your mom's turn!"
-Now we're gonna learn to driv
to the hospital.
Here we go.
This one's from @etes97.
She says...
[ Laughter, groaning ]
-Oh.
-What?
-How would you know?
-I mean, they're not even
my grandparents,
and I want to unsee that.
-Oh. Green light!
-Oh, man.
This last one's from
@krusty316.
He says...
There you have it. Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now, I thought I'd share some
of my favorite
"#RuinAMovieWithOneWord"
responses from you guys.
This first one is from
@HRreed1298.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @AnnieLifeson.
She says...
-Oh.
-See, see?
-One A Day.
-You're ruining it.
One A day.
This one's from @AskingSatan
-Ooh.
Satan?
-Asking Satan.
-Oh, okay.
-He says...
-Oh.
"Two more."
-This one is from @brigaz85.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-"Hey!"
[ Laughs ]
-This one's from @jackyboy223.
He says...
Oh, there you go.
That's a different movie.
This one's from
@badmovieman.
-Oh.
-Wow.
-This is right up his alley.
-Yeah.
-It's probably the best da
of his life.
@badmovieman.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-Ow.
Wow.
Ooh, family show.
-Alright, come on.
-[ Deep voice ] "Daisy."
-This one is...
-"Got to go make water."
-This is from @TheSwampRat
-[ Normal voice ] Swamp Rat?
-Wow.
-He says...
Ah, that's intriguing.
Totally different movie.
-"Winning!"
-This one's from @jpappone
He says...
This one's from @nickburesh.
Wow. These are
interesting names.
He says...
-Oh. You shall not pass.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's "Lord of the Rings",
but --
-There you go.
[ Applause ]
-Same thing.
-This one's from
@joeydestefano5.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-Now-ish. Sure.
This one's from
@ArtByPemPhoto.
He says...
This one's from
@bethinmaine2010.
She says...
-Oh, smack!
Oh! Oh!
Oh, no, you did not!
Wow! Wow.
She went there.
-Wow.
-"Cats"!
-Wow. Meow.
-Wow.
-Bing-bong-bong-boing.
Sssss.
-#RuinAMovieWithOneWord.
-Wow. "Cats".
-This one's from @ChrisEckst
He says...
"You damn, dirty vapes."
-"Have some --" [ Laughs ]
-This last one's from
@m3gannails.
She says...
There you have it.
Those are our hashtags.
Check out more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags